Ужгород - унікальне українське тилове місто.
Звідси до столиць восьми європейських країн, п’ять із яких є членами НАТО, ближче, ніж до Києва.
А саме місто буквально впирається в кордон зі Словаччиною.
Комендантської години у Закарпатській області не існує.
Обстрілювали регіон лише раз від початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Як живе найбезпечніший регіон України під час повномасштабної війни?
Скільки тут внутрішньо переміщених осіб та релокованого бізнесу?
І як VIP-переселенці готові були віддавати мільйони гривень за житло на Закарпатті?
Будень в Ужгороді. По набережній гуляють матері з дітьми, а кав'ярні переповнені людьми.
За час нашого перебування в місті ми не чули жодної сирени.
В Ужгороді взагалі безпечно. Це майже єдине місце в Україні, де безпечно.
Взагалі Закарпатська область. Комендантської години немає - це теж єдине місце.
А з тривогами - вони доволі часто. Доводиться теж іти в укриття, як і всі.
Пан Юрій - місцевий. Він військовий на пенсії.
На його думку, росіяни бояться обстрілювати регіон через близькість до кордону з країнами НАТО.
Один з моментів - те, що бояться. Тому що російська зброя  не є настільки точна, як вони там заявляли,
мовляв, друга армія світу, що в них дуже високоточна зброя, що вправо-ліво до 10 метрів.
Але я бачу, які в них похибки до 2-3 кілометрів. То вони і бояться стріляти.
А друге - ну, в принципі, Закарпаття за горами, за Карпатами, тому називається Закарпаття.
Це друга причина, що траєкторія польоту ракети теж одна з  причин.
Третя - немає військових об'єктів, які б дуже цікавили агресора.
Пан Юрій розповідає, що після початку повномасштабного вторгнення людей в Ужгороді стало майже вдвічі більше.
Вони відчувають себе тут у безпеці.
Рішення скасувати комендантську годину Закарпатська ОВА ухвалила ще на початку війни -
через велику кількість переселенців, релокацію бізнесу і роботу пунктів пропуску на кордоні зі Словаччиною.
Закарпаття піддавалось обстрілам тільки один раз.
Це було в гірській місцевості, били по інфраструктурі. Відповідно, більше прильотів не було.
І можна сказати, що Закарпаття - один з найбезпечніших регіонів серед інших регіонів України.
Тому сьогодні тут проживає велика кількість внутрішньо переміщених осіб.
Це, за оперативними даними, близько 350 тисяч.
За статистичними даними, там, де вони в громадах зареєструвалися, близько 140 тисяч.
Але ми розуміємо, що, наприклад, в літній період ще перебувають 500 і 600 тисяч.
Тому що люди хочуть відпочити і важливо їм надати таку можливість в такому регіоні,
де дійсно немає комендантської години.
Якесь психоемоційне перезавантаження все ж таки людина проходить тут.
Така безпекова ситуація допомагає регіону розвиватися попри війну.
У нас у результаті релокації є певний приріст в усіх бюджетах -
як у територіальних громад, так і в обласному бюджеті.
У загальному 127-130% приріст надходжень суто від економіки.
Це не має відношення військове ПДФО до цього.
Компаній релокувалося близько 400.
200 компаній релокувалося через міністерство економіки, як це передбачено законодавством.
Інші 200 компаній - це заново створені компанії, але ми розуміємо, що вони релоковані.
Одна з таких - компанія Soton, яка у січні цього року завершила релокацію виробництва в Ужгород із Дніпра.
Тут виготовляють полікарбонатну продукцію - для будівництва теплиць, рекламних щитів тощо.
До війни наші обсяги складали приблизно 400 тонн на місяць продукції.
Десь 20% було в Україні, 80% було на експорт.
Наразі ми повернулися до обсягів десь приблизно 150 тонн на місяць.
Дуже важко повертатися на ринок після перерви.
Ми були відсутні на ринку з лютого 2022 року десь приблизно по жовтень.
Ми взагалі не виробляли продукцію, ми стояли.
Ми демонтували спочатку одну лінію, і в вересні минулого року ми її запустили успішно в місті Ужгород.
Найважче у процесі релокації - перевезти працівників, каже керівник підприємства.
Адже вузькопрофільних фахівців знайти важко.
З усім іншим допомагала місцева влада.
Адже від такого переїзду виграють усі:
підприємство має можливість спокійно працювати,
а в місцевий бюджет сплачуються податки.
У довоєнні часи наше підприємство сплачувало десь приблизно 46-47 млн грн податків на рік.
Зараз ця сума суттєво менша, тобто зараз ми сплачуємо до 20 млн грн,
тому що в нас дуже малі обсяги порівняно з довоєнними.
Але це все йде на розвиток громад.
Крім того, завдяки релокованому бізнесу в регіоні створюються нові робочі місця.
У минулому році, у 2022-му, було створено близько 7 тисяч робочих місць.
Сьогодні ми фіксуємо приблизно таку ж кількість - створено ще 7 тисяч робочих місць.
Заробітна плата зросла у середньостатичного працівника,
оскільки велика кількість релокованих підприємств.
Є заробітні плати і 30, і 40 тисяч гривень, яких на Закарпатті ніколи не було.
Зворотна сторона медалі - на Закарпатті рекордно зросли ціни на оренду житла.
З початком повномасштабної війни ціни на оренду квартир в Ужгороді
зросли на 200% і стали найвищими в Україні.
VIP-переселенці готові були віддавати мільйони гривень за житло на Закарпатті.
Якщо до повномасштабного вторгнення орендувати хорошу однокімнатну квартиру
у новому будинку коштувало 400 доларів, то тепер ця цифра сягнула 800-900 доларів,
розповіла DW місцева рієлторка.
Звичайно, оренда вискочила не те, що на 100%, а на 200%.
Були просто дурні ціни на оренду, які піднімали власники.
Я вже не кажу, що в березні ціна була за хрущовку 1500 доларів.
Це за 3 кімнати, наприклад.
Чи 4-кімнатна - 2000 доларів.
Люди готові були платити.
Також суттєво зросли ціни на купівлю нерухомості - щонайменше на 30%.
Люди хотіли купити і купляли, скажімо так, приходили люди,
відкривали багажник і отак просто давали гроші.
Були моменти, що можна було купити, тобто пропонували за будинок мільйон,
і не хотіли продавати, розумієте?
- За мільйон доларів хтось хотів купити?
- Звичайно. Ціни були, так. І купляли, і легко купляли.
Різні були. Були, звичайно, дуже розбалувані, скажімо так.
Це були і багаті люди, які просто хотіли хороші умови.
Було таке, що перебирали, навіть коли не було, з чого вибрати.
Але вони не хотіли таке, вони хотіли щось хороше.
Багато селилися в готелі, в комплекси і там жили по пів року люди, і платили шалені гроші.
У менших містах та селах на Закарпатті ціни були значно нижчими.
Але багато переселенців хотіли жити саме в Ужгороді.
Зараз ситуація на ринку стабілізувалася, каже Тетяна.
Утім, довоєнними ціни вже не стануть ніколи.
Звичайно, зараз з'явився вибір.
Під час війни доробили дуже багато квартир, дуже багато.
Тобто їхня кількість зросла, якщо раніше, то за рік на відсотків 30-40 поповнився ринок новими квартирами.
Ціни знизилися, але не сильно. Тобто вони, скажімо так, стабілізувалися.
Тут багато заводів почали відкривати,  робочі приїжджають, тому попит завжди буде на Ужгород.
Я думаю, що ціни не будуть, можливо, аж настільки високі,  як зараз,
і, можливо, трошки воно заспокоїться, але не будуть такі, як до війни, це 100%.
Крім того, багато українців стали частіше приїжджати сюди на відпочинок.
Адже через війну великого вибору в українських відпочивальників не залишилося.
Я знаю, що люди відкривають бізнеси далі, відкривають комплекси відпочинку, бо цього не вистачає.
Якщо в минулому до війни ми хотіли кудись поїхати на вихідні відпочивати,
зняти якийсь будинок, то зараз це нереально зробити.
Це треба за пів місяця, за місяць щось бронювати, бо все забито.
Місцеві кажуть, що сюди переїхало також багато тих, хто ховається від мобілізації.
Дуже багато. І це відчувається. Причому, ну, не дуже порядні люди.
Я вам так скажу, що чому не дуже порядні:
по-перше, наших більше бригад воює там, а вони тут ховаються.
Це перше. Це не по-чоловічому.
А по-друге, в житті так складається: хтось воює, хтось ховається.
Ну, і з тих, хто ховається, великої користі немає на передовій.
Але свій військовий обов'язок вони повинні виконувати, як і всі.
Було важко дивитися на таких чоловіків,
ти не розумієш, чому, як, чому інші не йдуть, не хочуть, як вони можуть взагалі сидіти в кав'ярнях.
Це несприйняття було  повне...
Дехто боїться навіть по вулиці ходити.
Це проблема для бізнесу, тому що багато чоловіків бояться працювати, виходити на роботу.
Ми намагаємося регулювати це за рахунок комунікації з бізнесом.
Та все ж таки більшість переселенців - це жінки з дітьми і пенсіонери.
Вони втікали сюди від жахіть війни.
Це репетиція вистави "Тут жили поети" на вірші поетів, які жили в Маріуполі.
Її проводять актори Донецького драмтеатру з міста Маріуполь.
Їх прихистили у стінах Закарпатського обласного музично-драматичного театру.
У нас немає свого приміщення, ми орендуємо маленькі кімнатки тут у театрі,
і тому навіть посадити немає де людей.
Дуже очікуємо перемоги, хочемо повернутися.
Власного дому в нас вже немає, але хочемо знайти свій власний дім.
Хочемо, звісно, продовжувати цю лінію, яку ми тримаємо, лінію Українського театру Донеччини.
Ми вдячні Ужгороду за те, що він нас приймає вже півтора року.
Не все тут так тепло, як би хотілося нам.
Тому що ми живемо не вдома, живемо в гуртожитках і на квартирах.
Дехто втратив сім'ї, дехто втратив рідних.
Але, слава Богу, тут немає того жаху, що є на сході України, на півдні України.
І ми вдячнім ужгородцям за те, що вони нас приймають.
Як вони нас приймають, це залежить від людського фактора,  але ми вдячні ужгородцям.
Віра - одна з акторок, яка пережила бомбардування драмтеатру в Маріуполі
і першою приїхала в Ужгород відновлювати роботу театру.
16-го березня нас розбомбили. Дякувати Богові, жива залишилася. Дуже молилася.
Дякувати Богові, що встигли вискочити, тому що через п'ять хвилин,
мабуть, як ми вискочили з театру, почалися артилерійські обстріли.
А потім Людмила Леонідівна, коли їй запропонували в.о. директора,
вона мені подзвонила і каже: ви можете приїхати в Ужгород?
Там буде відновлення театру.
Я перша приїхала, сказала, що я залюбки, тому що треба працювати, треба жити,
треба виживати цей синдром якийсь, страх, треба якось було позбуватися.
Ужгородський замок, музей під відкритим небом,
греко-католицький кафедральний собор, вулиця Корзо
і набережна річки Уж - ці визначні місця ваблять туристів.
Та з початком повномасштабної війни люди приїжджали шукати сюди не розваг, а прихистку.
Сім'я Альфада Галімова приїхала в Ужгород з Ірпеня,
де вони жили після анексії Криму Росією.
Там вони виховували внуків і відкрили маленьке кафе у парку.
Ось таке у нас було маленьке кафе чи "точка" в центральному парку в Ірпені.
Вона відрізнялася від інших. Ви знаєте, що цікаво?
Ось це вулиця Чехова, це російський письменник.
А далі вулиця Лермонтова, а потім поворот на вулицю Пушкіна.
Потім прийшов "русскій мір" і показав нам, як повинні виглядати вулиці,
названі іменами їхніх письменників.
В Ужгороді родина переселенців теж не хотіла сидіти, склавши руки,
тому знову відкрили власний маленький бізнес.
Знайшли старий вагончик у парку, викупили його і відреставрували.
Ми вирішили, що повинні чимось займатися.
Ми не можемо бути на утриманні держави в такий важкий час.
Ми не можемо ходити просити допомоги.
Є сили, є досвід життєвий.
З того, що вдалося зробити, створили ось таку маленьку "точку".
Вона дає якийсь прибуток нам сімейний.
Дає можливість брати участь в якихось благодійних акціях.
Ну, і воно стало не звичайним кафе. Особливо в перший рік тут було дуже багато переселенців.
Це був майданчик для зустрічей, обміну думками.
А сам Ужгород, каже Альфад, зіграв важливу роль у житті багатьох переселенців.
В Україні є міста, які постраждали внаслідок прямої агресії.
Зруйновані будинки, квартали, страшно все...
А Ужгород виконав особливу місію у тилу.
У тилу теж триває війна.
Він забезпечив затишне перебування, розміщення та адаптацію десятків тисяч людей.
І я скажу, що ось це ставлення Ужгорода, взагалі закарпатців та адміністрації,
самих людей виконало дуже велику роль у тому,
що стримало дуже великий потік людей за кордон.
Багато хто, зупинившись в Ужгороді, вже не хотів їхати далі, в європейські країни.